well at any rate it's wonderful to be
here again and thank you for being here
with us we'll follow basically the same
procedures we did before make some
introduction that introductory remarks
and then we'll have Mr Blair continue
with the comments and discussion okay
let me just briefly sketch the road
traveled very briefly and then summarize
the last session and then make a few
comments about today's session so faith
in globalization faith is a major force
in the world that shapes also i'm sort
of globalization as a major force in the
world and the force also that shapes the
world of faiths and faith which have
abiding attractiveness and abiding power
and that at least that was the thesis of
the of the course that are able in
significant ways to shape globalization
processes we've floated a proposal that
precisely on the count of faiths shaping
power of globalization processes and
other cultural elements that go into
shaping of globalization we can speak of
one globalization in many cultural and
cultural registers and this mutual
influence of faith and globalization can
be seen on somewhat smaller scale
somewhat smaller scale in the
relationship between faith and economic
activity and that was the subject that
we have discussed last our last session
there we saw that market economies
market conditions influence the world of
faith uncertainties of contemporary
markets in the context of globalization
may lead people to Fay that's this one
piece that we read by Chinese scholar
analyzing resurgence of Christianity in
China but market economies also shaped
the way in which communities faith
communities are structured so-called
democratization of faiths as well as the
way in which the faith is transmitted
religious competition religious markets
are being talked about majority of our
time we spend talking about faiths
influence on market economy and there we
went strides
trade to the master of masters max
waiver and his own account of how
certain convictions religious
convictions in this particular case of
very esoteric conviction about
predestination shaped isn't it Eric it
is a so Terry for many folks Neil is not
quite sure that predestination and any
rate ha oh he just held on the numbers I
does more than I Neal no no he's good
now yes and no you gotta stop it okay so
we've got vs factor phone however you
want to describe for destination it has
shaped get an answer to her life
described his worldly asceticism that
had a very important role to play
according to waver in starting providing
a start for economic development market
economies connected with that also we
read the text by borrow who argued that
faith convictions when they encourage
trustworthiness and hard work and so
forth form essential form of capital
spiritual capital for the proper
functioning of organizations economy
sets of phone we also talked about faith
providing normative guidance for
economic activities mainly from the
readings that we had before and that is
from dalai lama john paul the second
justice questions as well as solidarity
questions that are being raised we also
talked about fades and the vision of
human flourishing that is the goal of
economic activities and in particular
there was the very end of john torn
store infants comments about
unsustainability of the type of economic
growth that is evidence in the west when
translated into China as well as the
rest of the world by implication and
then the questions of what kind of
conceptions of human life
and human flourishing we need so that
consumerist inputs would not necessarily
continue and here possible resources of
faith resources of faith in order to
address what it means to live one's life
well while one life wants life goes well
these are some of the issues that we
have we have discussed and as in many of
the sessions so also in the previous
sessions what we managed to do is place
things on the table less than explore
issues in detail and maybe that is the
value of this course because it is such
a high helicopter course now today we
are switching from globalization
processes and faith as traditions and
communities of faith and we're talking
zeroing in on a person of faith person
of faith that is publicly engaged there
is a personal in dimension all of all of
these individual persons are not only
influenced by globalization processes
they also do shape those processors my
first exhibit is a person sitting on my
on my left persons are not only shaped
by faith traditions they also carry
those faith traditions and shape them on
and person's individual persons matter
and matter in their profound way it's
not just because we believe in religious
traditions as well as in kind of
emerging globalized ethos the in human
rights and freedom and freedom of
conscience and so forth but also and
maybe importantly this may be
controversial because i think the
creative element that is introduced into
the affairs comes generally from an
individual person the novel the site of
novelty social novelty i think is the
person rather than processes at least i
would suggest who is a person of faith
well we had in mind primarily faiths as
faith traditions therefore in our case
here an individual who is embracing one
of the great faith traditions now you
can embrace one of the great faith
traditions in wide varieties of ways all
the way to
professor Blair talked about simply
identifying with with faith as your
aspect of your cultural identification
to this morning I heard McCain
mentioning him fumbling through his
faith or something like that all the way
to trying to be a saint a kind of
paradigmatic exemplar of what faith
means and i will name some of the
features of person of faith and i hope
to name features of the person of faith
with features with which great
contemporary leaders of communities
might all agree so if you had Dalai Lama
here benedict the sixteen Grand Mufti of
Egypt chief rabbi of of Jerusalem I hope
that they might agree with some such
description of what the person of faith
looks like but of course it's going to
be a matter for for discussion a person
of faith hold it faith expressed in
convictions practices and rituals
provides them with a comprehensive
though not exhaustive interpretation of
reality they also embraces normative an
account of self social relations and the
good defined by faith and they seek not
only to act in the coordinates of it
with this but to exhibit this in the
structure of their character and persons
of faith are often committed to and feel
accountable more or less to greater or
lesser degree to a broader body of Korra
legions their words persons afraid
generally don't come on their own they
come with a kind of social baggage so to
say whether they carry with them now
challenges of the public engagement of a
person of faith and I will just name
some of the things that in the course of
our readings and in the course of our
discussions and sections have have
emerged and one of those work was
connected and our primary discussion was
about the kind of obligations moral
obligations based on faith convictions
that the person smart have and in one of
our groups subgroups we've come up with
three C's in terms of the sources of
obligations
and that was conscience which is to say
the demands of immorality however those
demands are mediated either by positive
teachings of religion by kind of
utilitarian considerations or some kind
of combination of both conscience
demands of modern ality Constitution or
demands of the legal legal framework to
put it a little bit in broader terms and
then constituency demands of the
particular group of people whom a person
is serving and then we ask the question
well given those sources what is the
relative importance of those right how
do you rank those things and from our
reading and from our discussion it goes
all the way from you have to take care
only of your constituency and that may
be kind of a realist position in
Madeleine Albright's reading it's George
Kennan is represented by saying the
interests of national society for which
the government has to concern itself are
basically those of military security the
integrity of political life as well as
and the well-being of its people and
these are beyond moral evaluation beyond
good and evil some of the religious
folks might actually fall into that fall
into that account where they would say
we distinguish very carefully between
the private morality and public our
public public service most religious
folks would think that that's really
kind of betrayal of the main thrust of
the religious traditions others might
say well only Constitution and
constituency say a business leader we
discussed that on the basis of advanced
reading of Milton Friedman's text right
where he argues that you know a business
leader of a publicly traded company must
act within the league legal framework
and must increase shareholders profit
not much more it's on the shareholders
to decide what they'll do with their
their profit and do beneficial things
and then we talked about possibility of
all three conscience Constitution and
consistent consistent constituency three
C's got me confused being in play all at
the same time how that's done we can
leave open for discussion one question
that was a
rest was well how about religious faith
religious faith being and kind of
overarching interpretation of reality
and not just consisting of kind of
nuggets of wisdom which I may take or
may not take and its overarching
interpretation of reality which some
claim to truthfulness right it's not
just subjected preference how does that
fit into negotiating between these
various obligations and then we talked
about acting in public office on the
basis of moral teaching of specific
religion can one do that should one dude
obviously one can't do that right but
should one do that anyone should how it
is that one can do that advocating a
position for religious reasons for
instance but selling it on generally
acceptable grounds is that what the
stuff of good politics is made or is
some betrayal evidenced by something of
that of that sort or acting on informed
believe dictated by moral considerations
in a position to the wishes of
constituency which has elected you is
that what you're supposed to be in some
instances doing or is that in some sense
way of wronging the constituency that
has elected you so we also addressed a
bit and one of you in in in some of the
some of the emails swirling swirling
around has addressed the question of
limits clearly specifying the limits to
which people of faith can bring their
are their convictions the public a ring
so these kinds of things is that we have
discussed what we haven't discussed and
I what I think is also very important
and what doesn't come up very often in
our reading was the question of
character we talked about moral
obligation and bringing moral vision to
bear and public affairs an engagement of
a person of faith within a public realm
but we haven't read much or talked much
about the character of a person say the
trustworthiness of a person the courage
of a person that's demanded and what
might be the role of faith in shaping
not
just moral sensibilities but kind of
virtues and abilities of a person to act
in a certain way whatever the moral
dictates our it's one thing to have
clear a sense of what moral dictates our
butts the other matter of having the
ability to enact that in a situation of
crisis roughly that's what we've
discussed and that's the topic before us
today tied into what we've been doing in
the previous session and now I shall
pass on the baton to the main kick
that's not good well I have a personal
faith and iming publicly engaged so this
is this is a piece of bone self
psychoanalysis is much richer allegation
here it's just go back to the very basis
of what we're trying to explore here to
do with faith and globalization how do
we stop faith being a reactionary force
and how do we allow faith to play a
progressive and helpful role in ensuring
the modern world and globalization work
and what I want to suggest you today is
actually faith can be a way of making
what you identified at these three C's
the conscience constituency Constitution
it can be away I've actually aligning
those things properly in but plainly
equally it is possible that it can be a
source of tension between the three so
other some principles that we can draw
out that that that should guide us in
this area and as I say I kind of speak
from personal experience to somebody
who's been in public life is in public
life and is somebody of faith and i'm
not i'm not sure that my experience
necessarily
finds the experience of others but
anyway i will share it with you and i'd
also like to talk a little bit in fact
about faith and its role not just in
politics but in people who are engaged
in a business sense as well since i
think that's quite an interesting aspect
of the the crisis that's been there
going on for these last month's now
first and faith can undoubtedly be
problematic and even reactionary if
you're someone who is publicly engaged
it can be problematic for one very
obvious reason which is that if you say
you're a person of faith and you'll
publicly engage people tend to think
that every single thing you do is as a
result of some special relationship
you're claiming with with with with God
so you know what should the minimum wage
be you know the intricacies of health
care reform so how you're you're someone
who's sitting there referring everything
up to a higher power so it can there can
be a misunderstanding which can be
problematic and more seriously though I
mean politics is about compromising
there is very often a situation in which
you have to at least balance off
constituency and and conscience now if
you are a political leader you're
engaged in working often with countries
or regimes you may not like particularly
you may not agree with them particularly
on the other hand the interests of your
country may be very powerfully and
directly engaged and you have to to do
some balance there and there will be
times certainly where times for me in
which even though I didn't particularly
like doing business with these
particular people nonetheless I felt I
had to because the were there was such
strong interests of my country engaged
and I felt that I had a responsibility
to my country to do what is right by
them
there's also another area which can be
problematic which is that there can be a
direct disagreement between what the
organized part of your religious faith
says and what you may decide you want to
do actually for reasons of constituency
or or of conscience and I found myself
in this position for example in relation
to the issue of abortion we're even
though my churches are very clear line
about it I didn't actually agree with it
and you can find interest I think half
deals with this in terms of the
proportionate reason and so on but you
can find across a whole section of
policy that there can be a direct
conflict between what organized religion
says that you should think and what what
you you may actually think or you may
decide is is is necessary in the
interests your constituency so there's
no doubt at all that faith can be
problematic you know for those reasons
it can also of course be reactionary I
mean you know I think what's going to
own up to this right at the very outset
it is perfectly possible the religious
faith these user positions that are that
a reactionary that are that are a
regressive and not progressive at all so
for example there may be people whose
faith would lead them to believe that
women are second-class citizens or that
I gay people should not be allowed the
same rights as other people you know
there will be a situation also where
faith can be aggressive at the moment
leave aside all the obvious issues to do
with Islam but if you look at what is
happening in India at the moment from
the tensions between Christians and
Hindus it's it's in other words faith
for sure can
b and problematic and reactionary and
there can be a situation therefore where
if you've got someone who is a faith and
who's publicly engaged it can cause a
whole set of problems it can make the
country feel that maybe they're getting
something that it where the person is
obedient to an interest other than
theirs or it may actually mean that if
they follow certain dictates of
religious faith they end up in positions
that are unfair unjust reactionary and
if you say that you're a person of faith
people assume that compromise won't
happen when compromised often does now I
would put against that though the faith
and a person publicly engaged to is of
faith that this can have its positive
and progressive aspect and it can be
part of the solution so for example in I
think the the Johnson and Cox stuff on
faith-based diplomacy they show how
actually there are circumstances in
which have faith based diplomacy can
give a dimension to diplomacy that the
ordinary pragmatic diplomacy does not
but I think there are other reasons why
faith as part of a person in public life
can be positive
I think that political leaders who have
strong faith will tend I don't put it
more strongly than that because
sometimes they don't but will they will
tend to try to take value based
decisions in other words there is a
limit to compromise and expediency
that's not to say there isn't a
trade-off between your constituency and
your your conscience and even with your
Constitution but nonetheless I think
faith because it goes as miroslav was
saying to the issue of character faith
does at some point insists that you draw
a line around compromise in the
Expediency now let's leave aside where
that is right or wrong but for example
if you take a decision as I took in
several occasions to engage the military
conflict to get a war and leave aside
whether you agree or you disagree with
individual decisions but if you are
someone of faith it's not there isn't a
transmission like this is your faith
tells you that this is the right way to
decide this issue but in your assessing
of whether it's you're going to do it or
you're not going to do it the issue of
right or wrong is important and actually
in my view should outweigh the issue of
constituency or indeed I would even say
of Constitution these time I put that I
put that up as a as a question there now
that doesn't mean to say that you as I
say the decision may objectively be
right or wrong leave that to one side
for a moment the point is that there is
a dimension important into character in
that decision-making that is about where
do you think something is a beej into
your conscience or or not so
you know actually to give you a very
specific example in one of the military
conflicts I was engaged in actually had
a discussion with with another political
leader about whether this was the right
thing to do or the wrong thing to do and
he said well I'm already concerned about
that actually I am sure that it's in the
interest of my country to do it and we
had this rather curious to be where I
was saying well actually if that's the
only reason you think it it should be
done you shouldn't be doing it and I
think that faith in that sense can be it
can be progressive not you must
understand what I'm saying it not
because the decision is necessarily the
right decision but progressive in the
sense that issues to do with values and
right or wrong are a part of the
decision-making process right I think
also and that there is this limit as I
say to expediency or to compromise now
if you take this one step further and i
think that the handsome does is quite
quite well in terms of talking about
service I think faith also gives a sense
of service and I think it also gives a
sense of the long term that in other
words this is not something that is just
for your time it is for your time and
the next time as as well now if we try
and draw that out one step further in
respective of the current business
environment so what I'm really saying to
you is that that the faith can play this
problematic and reactionary role but it
also can and at its best give a sense of
strong values to a decision making
process that is in the end a beneficial
a beneficial part of that process
okay now i think if you take the current
economic crisis I think there's an
interesting read across here to do with
issues that our faith related issues and
notice I'm not saying you only get these
values through religious faith but I am
saying that religious faith often and at
its best does give rise to them so if
you take the current financial crisis at
the heart of it has been a loss of trust
and confidence but more than that in
certain parts of the system most people
I think would now except there has been
a failure to take account of anything
more than the very immediate interest in
the very short term now I think it was
you LeAnn who asked me we had an
exchange about globalization last time
wrong and I was kind of thinking about
that afterwards me thinking about it
principally in the context of realizing
that i was going to learn a lot more
from you guys than you were ever going
to learn from me leave that to one side
but I think I'd redefine what I was
saying to you and I think you you had a
better point that I thought you had when
I first heard it and
actually that's to be absolute find the
nearest a politician ever gets to
humility so bank bank that one is as
good as it gets I do you think you can
argue that in economic terms and we are
going to have to find a means of rien
jek ting values and trust into the
financial system for it to be coherent
and to work going forward and and you
know I was just because I'm seeing that
and still even though out of office
discussing it with people who are in
office about regulatory systems and how
you might regulate the capitalist system
and I think very quickly you realize
first that the danger is that you end up
regulating for the last crisis and
secondly that actually the whole point
about situations like this is that is
that they don't it's not really
regulation that makes makes the
difference ultimately it is about
whether the system has sufficient
integrity and and trust within it and so
if you think about those things that I
was saying faith brings the public
political life a sense of service a
sense of the long term a sense of
something more important than you a
sense that there is a limit to
expediency actually these are the things
too that would make a global economic
order work better for the future as well
so and as someone said to me earlier
actually also a sense that it's
important to do the right thing even
when no one's watching which i think is
a rut rather than a neat way of putting
what faith at its best should give you
you know so it's not it you've taken it
out of a sort of utilitarian question
about what is the you know simply if you
if you don't behave like this there's
going to be a penalty that comes upon
you
and you put into the realms of even if
there's no penalty and even if there's
no reward it's still good to do now the
final thing I'd like to say is this that
I think there are four reasons that i
wanta phi as to why why globalization
needs faith in public life you know is
all the way through you know a lot of
what we're talking about and in the
sessions between the last time we met I
mean you're analyzing secularization and
economic development and religion and so
on and so forth and much of what we are
about is trying to work out how we stop
religion being a force that ends up
being destructive and and resulting in
conflict and destruction and disaster
and so on and yet and actually when you
the bits that i read actually Thomas and
the quotes he was making on voltar
bigoted reports anyway basically they
they assume that there is a
contradiction between faith and
globalization and they they assume that
in the end and the two are bound to come
into conflict and therefore start to
pull people apart now here are the four
reasons why I think that's not true and
that actually faith properly defined is
part of how we make globalization work
and what globalization needs the first
reason is that by faith by giving you a
broader sense of narrow self-interest or
even narrow national self-interest
actually speaks to the condition of the
world today if you take any of the major
issues that we face
and take to that unrelated to the
financial crisis take climate change for
example or take poverty in Africa I
would argue that and you cannot resolve
either of those two issues you cannot
resolve the threat to our environment
from the changing of the climate unless
you are prepared to take a broader view
than your own narrow national interest
in other words if you simply pursue your
national interest where is not going to
work you have to take a broader view and
you have to do that in collaboration
with others and by doing it in
collaboration with others the only basis
in which that can work it is is
equitable so likewise with Africa I mean
for the world to ignore Africa is not in
itself interest to do as as we go
forward if Africa becomes shut off from
the the progress the rest of the world
is made we will have disaffected
alienated people in large number and we
will have a huge potential source of
trouble for the future now there may be
there are moral reasons why we should
act but the point is this faith which
gives us a sense that your interest is
more than just about you but is about
something bigger than you is actually
important in a geopolitical sentence
given the way the world is today because
of global community facing global
challenges demands global action that
cannot happen unless people are prepared
to act with enlightened self-interest ie
enlightened in the sense that you take
account of the interests of others in
defining your own interest secondly I
think that faith is is part of what
globalization deeds because
there is one huge and defining priority
for any domestic government for any
people in public life today who want to
make a success of their country that is
the development of human capital and I
think faith again not the only but by
believing an essential human dignity and
the belief that opportunity should be
available to everybody are not
restricted to a few or not simply
allowed to come as it comes then faith I
think helps in terms of public policy by
saying it has got to be an imperative
for our country and indeed us in
conjunction with other countries to help
those other countries develop their
human capital provide education for all
make sure that that that people are
getting the opportunities that a present
are available to a small number but
should be available to a larger number
so thirdly i think that faith because it
is it is about values i think
yeah it's only if you are able to
persuade the global community that an
action is indeed values-based by which i
really mean just and fair that you can
get support for it now let me just
explain what what I mean by that if we
take this issue to do with global
terrorism I am convinced even though I
think it is necessary in certain
circumstances to take security action or
to take military action I am convinced
that the answer to this lies at the
level ultimately of ideas rather than of
security action so in other words unless
you can persuade people that there is a
better idea out there to match the
ideology that is galvanizing this
extremism then we will not succeed now
that idea has got to be rooted in a
concept of justice and justice for all
irrespective of you know your own nation
but broaden that it's one of the reasons
why in another part of the work that I
do that in the Middle East I think we
will not restore relations between the
west and Islam to what they should be
unless there is justice for for the
Palestinian people in a way consistent
with Israel security but justice for
them so in my view what faith in terms
of public engagement does is it
it allows us and helps us to meet the
case for global action based on global
values because it allows us to persuade
people of the validity of our ideas by
its appeal to essential values to do
with justice and equity fairness
equality human dignity and finally I
would say that that faith can be a part
of making globalization work because the
system works through confidence the
system is essentially fragile precisely
because it is interconnected and
interdependent and it depends on
confidence and that's true for politics
and is true for business and therefore
values based policy is in these
circumstances a way of making the system
work now what this means in my view
therefore is that faith
as defined by a strong set of
convictions beliefs and values that are
over and above yourself either
personally or your narrow national
self-interest that are long-term and
intergenerational as well as merely
short-term that are about service of
others and for others faith can unite
the constituency the Constitution and
the conscience because the conscience in
these circumstances actually aids the
constituency since you the pursuit of
your national interest in a global
community has to be pursued in
conjunction and an alliance with others
and usually because that means that is
value-based it is in line with your
Constitution now all of this
does not mean that you can't get to the
same position even in our personal
religious faith you can do and one of
the things that's interesting about this
whole issue to do with faith and
globalization is that you will notice
that I speak about faith as giving
people a strong sense of values and
something bigger than themselves now
that is my view virtually I would say a
universal tenant of faith so that most
certainly Abrahamic face but I think
more broadly than that say love your
garden love your neighbor as yourself
it's a very very common position now
it's possible to have those positions
and not of any religious faith at all of
course it is yeah and one of the things
that we have to explore in in the in
this courses to what extent are we
saying faith is the route to making
globalization work or faith is merely a
route now my view is that you cannot say
that it is the only route nonetheless
however it is a major route because it
does face does route a person and a
country and a culture in strong values
however faith only performs that
positive and progressive role if it is
defined not through exclusionary
doctrine but inclusionary values in
other words everything that I am saying
about faith today and the difference it
makes or could make to globalization
only applies if we are prepared to look
at faith and to engage in faith in
public life as based on a set of values
that can include others of different
faiths and indeed of no faith rather
than as a set of exclusionary doctrines
which put you in difference to the other
person and that brings me back to the
point really right at the very beginning
which is that religious faith could be a
reactionary force or it could be
progressive but if it is values-based an
inclusionary then in fact in a global
community in which countries need to
pursue their interests in a more broad
way than simply their own narrow view of
self-interest it is and can be a major
positive force